five-year-old william pacheco doesn't
like getting vaccinated but his mother
elizabeth couldn't be happier he suffers
from a rare disease she says he
sometimes runs from the house putting
his life in danger but now he is
protected
now i'll be relaxed with the vaccine i
know that he will be protected because
at some point he gets infected i won't
be afraid that he could die
peru's government has launched a
vaccination campaign for five to 11 year
olds the aim is to vaccinate 4.3 million
nationwide
the omicron variant has health workers
worried especially here at the national
institute of children's health doctors
here treat rare or grave medical
conditions
the covert cases have increased in two
years we've treated 5 000 children with
respiratory conditions and 350 were
covered this year alone we already have
800 patients diagnosed and it's because
of omicron
the health ministry says nearly 850
children have died after contracting
coronavirus since the pandemic began
infected children occupy two thirds of
all intensive care beds
the health minister says the number of
children who test positive for covet 19
is likely to rise this as health
authorities warn they are close to
issuing a red alert as there are only a
few icu beds left for children around
the country
doctors and parents hope the vaccination
campaign goes swiftly especially because
schools are expected to reopen in march
for two years most children have
remained at home leonie lopez says his
seven-year-old boy's neuropathic illness
worsened
the need to walk and walk the stress of
not going out seeing friends or the
countryside being in open spaces has
been very hard for them
[Music]
experts say the lockdown has had a
devastating psychological effect on kids
but leonie says his son can make up for
some of the lost time and get some
relief with the certainty though that he
is protected against the virus mariana
sanchez al jazeera lima peru